and good evening to you at 11 I'm Brian
Loftis it's a major construction project
that feels like it will never end Paving
near the Las Vegas Strip ahead of the
big Formula One race in November now
people say the main issues have moved to
Harman between Las Vegas Boulevard and
coval and those who have to drive
through there every day are just fed up
Sasha Loftus joining us live in the area
tonight with more Sasha
this construction for quite a while now
now it has moved off the Las Vegas Strip
for now but a lot of the main issues
here as you said are on hormone you can
see a lot of cones up and those Lanes
down to one lane in each Direction those
who have to drive through here every day
say it can't end soon enough
dealers every day just crazy it may not
be new but it certainly still
frustrating
local drivers sharing their concerns
over continued Formula One Construction
the first round of Paving wrapped up on
Las Vegas Boulevard a few days ago but
now the nightmare has moved here
on Harmon between the strip and coval oh
it is dangerous because it's like the
traffic and so many people walking in
tourists people get hit all it's crazy
many local drivers like Savon Mill say
they have to give themselves at least an
extra half hour to get through the area
safely he says winding lanes and rolling
closures cause a myriad of issues going
North toward Flamingo is killing
everybody and Jimmy tells us he and
other local Uber and Lyft drivers worry
it's only going to get worse in the
coming months as the big travel season
ramps up summertime is coming up people
are coming for summer vacations these
cone zones are set to last into
September
and since f1's deal lasts through 2032
many also worry this will happen all
over again next year I can't wait till
they just clear all this stuff out and
just get the right Formula One so
drivers who deal with this all the time
say anyone heading through should buckle
up and plan to ride this all out for the
4 foreseeable future
now the main Paving here on Harman is
set to last through the rest of this
week at least then that heavy work will
move down to coval on June 11th the
second round of main painting on the Las
Vegas Strip is on tap to start up again
in July reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 news now Sasha thank you for
that this is a look at the upcoming
Formula One Construction schedule we
also have this posted over on
8newsnow.com Formula One race weekend
set for November 16th through the 18th